springing Bob Nightingale covers the
sport what do you think of these
proposals well I just don't see it
happening again first of all there's no
way they're gonna play in a plastic
bubble in Arizona it just doesn't make
sense you can't protect the safety of
all the players under one roof and
everything else staying in hotels
sometimes you know some of those little
changes have been discussed but I think
they can happen at any time I think even
if they we have a season with fans you
know later in the summer I could see
some that taking effect but why are they
putting this out here Bob then if you
don't think that this is really possible
why are they floating these ideas I
think we just floated like okay if we
get the health thing worked out if all
of a sudden magically we have testing we
can test on the spot and get results but
there's no way in the world baseball is
going to do this when the public doesn't
even have it baseball would get
crucified just logistics the of everyone
playing in Arizona 30 teams in Arizona
and are they isolated from their
families yeah which is a big drawback so
how many guys are families I'm gonna say
okay I'll see you later honey gods next
four and a half months sorry I know
you're pregnant but I'll miss the baby
and things like that and you're taking
reduced pay hey when there's no games
all fans these players aren't to be paid
a hundred percent they're gonna have to
take a big take that too just like the
owners are so all kinds of problems what
are the other options here bum well the
big thing is kind of sit back and wait I
think that they've talked about some
medical stumped Dan where you almost
feel like you didn't see the blade
tournament and now brackets but you know
Sade you start the season in September
play through until Thanksgiving kind of
a very short regular season and maybe
just a wild type of incidentally you
know November man is that thing for
baseball but they're they're looking at
place some kind of games get some of the
revenue back at least do something but
they're certainly not going to rush into
this well you also have Scott Boras
which I understand why he's putting this
let's play baseball until after
Christmas how do people react it okay
that's how they reacted they laugh which
I said no that's crazy
but he's trying to get his you know
people paid right right and that's the
thing yeah just like your head he's got
a big overhead you know all these agents
are getting paid either the players got
bills everybody wants to get their money
but that money is not going to come so
they're not going to come into a hundred
percent yeah
the owners are saying the revenue just
from the ballpark concessions parking
all that is about you know thirty five
percent you know as explained to me if
your New York Mets and you're playing
games and in Phoenix are you going to
sell advertising race a Citi Field and
that sort of thing so a lot a lot of
money you just won't be coming in and
you know if your player do you really
want to take a huge pay cut in plane 100
to 110 degree heat in Arizona without
your tongue is going around and you're
not yearning allowed to go out because
all the bars and restaurants are closed
your buzzkill Bob today I thought maybe
I I was I was promising hope on today's
show you know they really want to get
going I mean the Union wants to get you
play the owners want to play everybody
else but it's just like you know let's
don't you know for speed to say let's
take some time you know I don't know how
all these other events are getting
canceled and baseball says oh we were
the only sport that's going to have the
magical cure and the testing and
everything else you know you already
have government officials in Arizona
popping up and saying wait a minute now
we didn't have these tests for our own
people that live here and we're gonna
give them for the athletes that come
from all around the world and give them
special treatment
you know what concerns me is these
commissioners who keep putting out these
timelines and and it's just I don't it's
not dangerous but it's false hope
there's where you said hey maybe if we
have baseball in May and we have a two
week spring training and then we I
thought Adam silver did the right thing
the NBA commissioner he said look I'm
not gonna give you any timeframe the
rest of this month let's reassess when
we get to May
it feels like baseball is is trying too
hard to make this work instead of
letting it come to them they're trying
to go after this and you can't no you
can't you know I think you know Simon
was that big you know pep talk where
they got Donald Trump you in a day with
all the commissioners and okay hey less
worse let's do everything possible we're
behind you whatever you guys can do to
help out you know the entertainment
business and all that so I think part of
its from that Bagri with you I think
Adam silver you know what's perfectly
said you know don't even talk to me we
don't know what's going on you know
until May until then so it's just way
too way too much of a rush to say nay I
mean I don't see how that's possible
and also how you're gonna manage your
pitching staff at if it's a 100 game
schedule season let's just let's just
say it is are you gonna be able to add
more players to the roster I think
there's a lot of questions that are left
to be answered if if we do play baseball
what's it look like with your roster you
know if we do these double headers you
know having a nut amount of pitchers are
you going to be able to add a couple of
pitchers here what are your thoughts on
that
I definitely add three guys Dan so it's
about 26 man roster it's 26 year this
year and said the usual 25 go to 29 30
maximum but you're right you're gonna
need more pitchers just like we did in
the after 94-95 work stoppage and do
that that's I'm not sure seven innings
you'll make sense to help out pitchers
but you know baseball is so big you know
history and record books everything else
all of a sudden we see all these
complete games and no-hitters it's like
wait a minute now your chances
everything yes who would be the
overwhelming favorite to win it all this
year if we do play baseball I might kick
before this all came about was it was
the Dodgers over the Oakland A's I think
the Dodgers are loaded I love that
Mookie Betts trade I think David Price
grew up in the AL East to the Badger
State and pitching in that division off
ballpark you know he could be a sy young
guy again so I thought there were the
big time favorites and I will say this
layoff though
you know even though I thought I was
gonna crush the Houston Astros with
everything that blow throughout the road
the baseball comes back I don't know how
much you know fans let me jump all the
Astros was like with all week we've gone
through and we really going to blew
these guys and we'd really care that
much about baseball cheating in light of
what the what's going on with the rest
of the world so I think it actually
favors yeah it's a break for the Astros
because people aren't gonna give them
such a hard time and now you get Justin
Verlander to be healthy by the time this
thing resets if it does good stuff Bob
Hope you're safe and we appreciate your
time even though you're a buzzkill today
that's Bob Nightingale USA Today
baseball columnist